calm cool and collected christoph
cononengisa is the consummate
professional
since he's the head of the german
african business association media
outlets often seek coneguisa's views of
the ebola epidemic
he says the response of some western
companies is overly alarmist
it doesn't make sense to cancel trade
fairs in ghana or visits by delegations
to namibia and south africa
places that are three thousand
kilometers away from the source of
infection
we shouldn't let the ebola pandemic
stigmatize the entire continent
is also preparing for a visit to africa
later this week the 51 year old is
leaving his wife and two children behind
in berlin for a few days in order to
accompany 20 german business leaders to
the democratic republic of congo and
congo brazil
he'll be accompanied by press officer
carla nickel
ebola is also spreading in the
democratic republic of congo
but what do your family and friends say
do they think you're crazy
many do but others know i'm constantly
in africa
i just spent six months in burundi
this is the first time my mother's
questioned it
but after two minutes i was able to
convince her it's not a problem
there haven't been any infections in the
places we'll be visiting
so we think the risk that will run into
trouble there is absolutely negligible
and that's true of our participants too
we haven't had any panicky or hysterical
inquiries
the registrations have been coming in at
a constant rate
the association represents german
economic interests in africa
members include consultancies
commodities trading and exploration
companies
and a range of mid-sized firms
some members will be attending the event
tonight
the prime minister of the democratic
republic of congo is in berlin
has been prime minister since 2012.
before that as finance minister he
helped make his country of more than 70
million into one of africa's fastest
growing economies
in his speech ma paul cited a growth
rate of more than 8 percent
and called it a major opportunity for
german business
he also addressed the health risks
part of the northern province of
eccatura has seen some cases of ebola
but they're limited to that region
today we can tell you we're not worried
because our experts and physicians have
it under control
i believe the germans will be very safe
on their visit to democratic republic of
congo
security democratic
and what do the german companies say
many know the region well
alois de lemon heads a consultancy that
provides hospital and healthcare advice
to african governments
i'm not sure what the prime minister
meant when he said they had things under
control and had undertaken measures
blocked off the region
but since the roads and transport routes
aren't very good
it's hard to get out anyhow
it's fairly far away
so i don't think there's a risk
the business representatives agree ebola
is no reason to avoid africa not even
the democratic republic of congo where
the virus has broken out in some regions
it's a positive message that prime
minister mapong can take home
you